et avant de refermer cette édition je
vous rappelle cette principale
information de nos journalistes ont été
arrêtés à la frontière entre la pologne
et la biélorussie alors qu'ils
exerçaient leur métier ils ont été
embarqués par la police au moment où il
faisait 1 l'intervention directe depuis
le village de route nargorny en pologne
à une centaine de mètres de la frontière
ils sont actuellement dans un
commissariat où ils sont en tentant
entendu par la police pour s'être rendu
dans une zone
interdite voilà il s'agit donc de david
et khalifa et de jordi demory nous
allons également parlé de cette
situation de la situation de nos
journalistes avec notre invité dominique
pradalié secrétaire générale du syndicat
national des journalistes
sony fera la liaison jour merci d'être
en direct avec nous ce matin on vient de
le dire un au journaliste david khalfa
est gentil de mon riz ont été arrêtés
par la police polonaise à quelques
mètres de la frontière avec la
biélorussie alors d'après nos premières
informations ils ont été arrêtés dans
une zone interdite par les autorités
polonaises est ce que finalement
aujourd'hui le droit de la presse fort
est une exception pour par les
journalistes dans ces zones
mais le droit de la presse gilles
versier de partout y compris dans les
zones qui est interdite c'est notre
mission de journalistes d'aller là où
les événements se produisent pour en
rendre compte et ainsi informés des
citoyens donc si votre équipe a été
arrêté ce n'est pas bien et nous
souhaitons de toutes nos forces qu'elles
soient libérés immédiatement carré n'y a
aucune raison de détenir des
journalistes qui cherchent juste à
effectuer leur travail
ce que vous avez on peut dire qu'ils
aiment certaines entraves à la liberté
de la presse on vous
aubin ya pas une certaine entre avis à
une entrave certaine à la liberté de la
presse partout et particulièrement en
france mais aussi dans tous les pays où
maintenant on ose dire aux journalistes
dehors dehors comme s'il s'agissait d'un
trou d'ennemis alors que la liberté de
la presse est la même pour tout le monde
y compris pour celles et ceux qui
veulent nous empêcher d'exercer
quelles sont les garanties qu'offre
aujourd'hui le droit européen concernant
cette liberté de la presse
mais écoutez c'est très simple si
l'article 10 de la convention sauvegarde
des droits de l'homme qui implique que
les journalistes doivent pouvoir exercer
absolument partout
restant effectivement à régler le
problème des exceptions qui sont très
très rares et qui sont jugés au coup par
coup quand un journaliste soit s'est mis
en danger soit aurait mis en danger
quelqu'un mais en dehors de ça chez le
droit d'informer et surtout d'être
informé
concrètement quand on assiste à ce genre
d'événement voilà des journalistes qui
sont arrêtés alors qu'ils font leur
métier là en l'occurrence ce sont allés
story t polonaise que risque tels que
risque votre équipe que risquent les
autorités ou plutôt la pologne justement
d'avoir voilà arrêté chez moi j'avais
passé votre votre question les autorités
qui arrêtent
indûment des journalistes ou des simples
les citoyens ne risque quasiment rien ou
très peu c'est pour ça qu'elles le font
on peut faire impression peut le gagner
ça prend des années d'énergie etc nous
le ferons si nous devons le faire mais
en attendant effectivement le but qui
est empêché les journalistes de
témoigner sur un an atteint par les
autorités puisque pendant ce temps là
les joris ne pourront pas témoigner de
ce qu'ils savent de ce qu'il voit pour
leurs concitoyens est ce que c'est un
phénomène courant aujourd'hui voilà dans
des zones à risque que les journalistes
se retrouvent parfois dans ce genre de
situation
parfois oui et à chaque fois les
serviettes aux côtés de celles et ceux
qui portent plainte
et nous avons en général des succès dans
ces plaintes mais effectivement le but
principal de l'autorité qui agit et
d'empêcher tout témoin de voir ce qui se
passe quant aux quelques centaines ou
peut-être que milliers de malheureux qui
est lorus de malheureux
pardon migrants que les biélorusses et
les polonais sont rois c'est une honte
pour l'europe et pour nous tous car ils
sont très peu par rapport aux dizaines
ou centaines de millions de l'europe
nous devrions les accueillir
immédiatement cette union pardonnez moi
si mon côté citoyens merci beaucoup en
tout cas dominique pradalié d'avoir
accepté de réagir sur notre antenne
voilà je le rappelle à nos journalistes
deux journalistes à qui et qui voilà qui
sont sur place pour témoigner justement
de la situation à la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne ont été
arrêtés ce matin nous reviendrons plus
en détail dans nos prochaines éditions